[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight there is a
loud debate going on in washington right
now one that we participate in about
border security whether to build a wall
how much funding ice should get
whether our detention centers are big
enough to hold everyone they need to
hold
people argue about these questions every
day you watch it on tv and so it seems
like the parties are divided on the
matter
but on a deeper level there really is no
debate there is instead consensus
virtually everyone in our political
system knows as an article of faith
that mass immigration is good for our
economy
immigrants make us richer the chamber of
commerce tells us that
often libertarian think tanks produce
studies claiming to prove it's true
in the democratic party it is a bedrock
principle
america would collapse without a steady
torrent of new arrivals from the
developing world that's what they tell
us
immigration doesn't just improve the
economy we wouldn't have an economy
without it i want us to be a country
where hard working immigrants who pay
taxes and by the way
one half of undocumented workers pay
federal income taxes these people are
just waiting
waiting for a chance to be able to
contribute fully
and by that standard 11 million
undocumented aliens are already
americans in my view
we can't continue to grow this economy
unless we grow more diverse and take it
more immigrants
our history and the facts show that
immigrants are a net plus for our
economy
and our society half of illegals pay
their taxes says hillary clinton you
should be impressed and grateful
well this is not a new talking point as
you could tell from the aging video we
just showed you
but like everything in this country it
has accelerated dramatically in the past
couple of years
the left's new position is that
immigrants aren't just good for america
they're better for america than you are
they don't complain they don't file hr
complaints
they don't get expensive long-term
diseases like diabetes or opioid
addiction
they just do what they're told they're
the noble workers our leaders have
always wanted
just two days ago senator kirsten
gillibrand of new york who by the way is
running for the president
explained that every single immigrant in
america is
good no matter how they got here or why
just by virtue of the fact that they're
immigrants ever heard anyone say that
about american citizens
no and don't hold your breath but
gillibrand clearly meant it about
immigrants watch
there is no such thing as an illegal
human
you have immigrant populations across
the state refugee populations that make
your economy stronger that make
your city and states stronger that make
this country stronger
falsest person in washington but she's
saying something that everyone else
believes immigrants make our economy
stronger
okay that's the claim is it true well in
some cases it is true plenty of
immigrants have done a great job
in this country they are highly
patriotic they're successful in business
they are great neighbors and friends
everybody knows people like that and
everybody's glad they're here
but not every immigrant is like every
other immigrant now don't tell kirsten
gillibrand
but they're not all the same our current
immigration system treats them like they
are
it treats people like widgets our
government does virtually nothing to
separate the good from the bad a system
like that is not designed to help
america
it's designed for the benefit of
foreigners and by that measure it has
been
wildly successful a new study shows that
just last year
immigrants living in the united states
sent at least 120 billion dollars in
remittances to the countries they came
from
even in an age of expanding costs 120
billion is a lot of money
it's more for example than we spent on
the first gulf war
it's more than the entire russian
military spends every two years
that's enough money to buy costco not
the stuff on the shelves
but the entire company and still have 15
billion dollars left over
it's a lot of money and all of it could
be going to americans many of whom badly
need it
but instead mexico received 33 billion
dollars in remittances just last year
that country's own president admits the
mexican economy would go under
without those remittance payments in
guatemala remittances from the united
states amounted to a full
11 percent of their entire gdp
in el salvador and honduras that's 18
and 20 percent respectively
in the past decades those three
countries have received a total of 120
billion in remittances for the united
states
and by the way it's not just latin
america that's benefiting from this
china
which hardly needs it gets 15 billion a
year into
remittances india 10 and a half billion
vietnam 7 billion
nigeria 5 and a half billion russia 300
million we could go on and on
now none of this is an attack on
immigrants in most cases they're just
helping their families back home and
good for them it's not their fault
it's our fault much of this money has
never been taxed at any level
more than 10 million illegal aliens are
believed to be working in this country
under the table
and that's part of the reason that
between 2012 and 2016
an estimated 39 million social security
numbers were stolen from americans for
fraudulent use
a fact that's rarely reported but legal
or not immigrants send their earnings
abroad and they pay
nothing when they do it because
remittances are untaxed
it's a pretty good deal for mexico and
guatemala when was the last time you
made a financial transaction that
wasn't taxed can you even remember at
one point the trump administration
proposed a remittance tax
lobbyists from mexico didn't like the
idea the idea went nowhere
we can't fix that on this show what we
can do is be honest about what is
happening
immigration is good for our economy sure
it can be good
immigration is always good for our
economy more immigration is always
better for our economy
no that's a lie there is nothing to
support that claim
there's a lot of evidence to disprove it
anyone who tells you that and that's
pretty much
everyone you see on television either
doesn't understand the subject or is
lying to you purposefully and maybe both
just so you know